jour ça va pour très bien voici pour
faire partie du jury de ce prix
angénieux c'est important de le
récompenser les directeurs et
directrices en tout cas pour moi
ma nièce dame et je suis ici a été une
des personnes qui va qui m'a permis de
doses et de me laisser filmer d'avancé
en tant que comédienne
il ya quelque chose de course était très
important de venir battre et travailler
avec
on était deux fois ici on les écoles et
les égarés et aussi son fils de
catherine corsini par seconde à relation
entre un acteur et actrice et metteur en
scène a rétabli rarement c'est le
premier run a sur notre peau est quelque
chose de très bien de ce fait dans dans
le rapport et puis c'est celui qui
permet d'oser unis voilà il changé ma
vie les dernières secondes avant que les
parties sa maman par ici mais c'était
impensable après ce confinement de maka
parti veut pas dire que la culture est
essentielle et donc
la rue manuel merci beaucoup l'accès